On commence sur une anecdote de qualité
j'ai appris récemment que quand je parle et que je m'appuie sur la gorge comme ça je risque de me créer des nodules sur les cordes
vocales et des nodules quand c'est extrêmement grave
eh ben tu fini par perdre tes cordes vocales voilà donc ça m'a mis en pls toute la nuit donc ne me dites plus ce genre
de choses, je dors mal après! Les amis il y a quelques temps nous avons testé mon skill en géographie qui est équivalent au tien
sur Overwatch, à savoir bronze. Souvenez-vous on
commençait sur une vue aérienne d'une ville très zoomée, et on pouvait
dézoomer un petit peu et fallait deviner de quelle ville il s'agissait. Aujourd'hui on est sur
GeoGuess alors il y a plein de gens qui ont déjà fait des vidéos dont Amixem d'ailleurs, mais ! Je m'en bats les couilles ! Géo
guess ça utilise google street ça veut dire que tu te retrouve vraiment dans les rues de la ville je pense personnellement que c'est plus facile
de deviner où tu es quand tu es dans les rues
de l'endroit où tu es (horrible cette phrase) plutôt que d'avoir une vue aérienne on se rend compte de rien là c'est parti(Aie).
La géographie de Squeezie
partie 2
ok on est dans le jeu! Oh attends ça va m'aider ça, Gas Licuado de de petroleo YES! Merci camion! Y a marqué en Espagnol!  c'est pas comme si il y avait 1 milliards de pays qui parlait Espagnol, EH BAH SI!
Ok ça va être à base d'inspecteur squeezie.
La maison la bas le toit est de travers .Alors est-ce que c'est lié à la caméra 360 de Google ? Sûrement. Sur ce camion c'est marqué en espagnol, d'accord?
C'est un pays où on roule à droite comme en Espagne et peut-être aussi au Mexique peut-être aussi tous les autres pays
où ça parle espagnol.Putain!
Nan mais attend ce qui est bien c'est qu'on peut se déplacer on va aller voir la bas mais comme dans un repaire de routard mon pote,c'est incroyable.Il y a que
des camions le climat a l'air plutôt sec ''Casebas Plan
uno suarez'' Mec c'est en Espagne ou c'est où attend ? ''Acceso de servicio ''.Y'a une station service? J'ai vraiment l'impression d’être Inspecteur Squeezie, c'est
génial !
Attend, ct'oiseau c'est pas un pélican hispanique du sud-est?Non je sais pas. ''Robles hôtels et cabanas''.Soit on est en Amérique du Sud, soit on est en Espagne.
''Atencion a 500 MTS, cruce de rutas''.
Mec j'pense c'est Espagne !  C'est parti.
Ou est l'Espagne ?
Ok.  Ok, j'ai mis le curseur sur l'Espagne. Attention...
*Roulements de tambour*
Ahhhh ! Rien à voir !
J'étais à dix mille quatre cents kilomètres de la location (localisation ^^') correcte. On était en argentine putain
Ah non mais mec c'est trop chaud de savoir
On va se rattraper, alors il y a un drapeau mec,  vert blanc rouge
attend puisque là on le voit pas très bien cette si je vais là il y aura un peu moins de vent et on le
verra mieux , non c'est encore PIRE , attend faut que je trouve là où on voit parfaitement le drapeau... Ah non l'arbre !
Ahhhh ! Y a marqué  stop donc c'est en français(le mec trop con).
Je pense c'est le Canada mec.CANADA
OUIII,  j'ai reconnu!
*Accent québecois nul* Tabarnak, chui aller y po longtemps et
j'ai reconnu le drapeau vert blanc rouge rouge blanc vert je sais déjà plus avec la
feuille d'érable que j'arrivais pas discerner à cause du vent .Merci à tous merci c'est tout pour moi
Mec !
3000 points on était qu'à 900 kilomètres. Bon après par contre où au canada calme-toi et reste tranquille en chien(???) merci.
Vous savez que Paris, montréal ça fait quatre fois paris mais il y a deux fois plus d'habitants à paris qu'à montréal.Ca fait réfléchir
les neurones alors Oh ! sa mère climat
extrêmement violent la chaleur est totale nous sommes au milieu de la campagne il y a énormément de verdure et de poussière nous sommes en plein cagnard
il y a de la fumée on ne sait pas pourquoi par terre. Ah ok puisque je regarde derrière
là d'où vient la voiture google
donc je me tape les projections. Oh il y a une vache ! je vais avancé j'irai au bout de cette route j'en ai rien à
foutre. C'est parti.
Est-ce que la vache avait plus l'air de venir des U.S ou d'Afrique , c'est ça la vraie question, il faudrait qu'on retrouve une vache...une
maison il y a deux autres vaches
on les voit à peine attend....
C'est au U.S ( x3 ) elle était en train de manger un burger mon pote c'est au U.S c'est obligé
c'était....c'était où ? Quel est-ce pays ? au sud sud du brésil mais mec c'est abusé putain
Mais regarde , regarde où il me met , je suis dégoûté
putain mec mais cette bâtarde de vache elle s'est dit "je vais trompé tous les joueurs en mangeant un hamburger" je la haie . Mec tout est
pareil. Tu sais quoi je dirais que c'est l'australie tout est pareil tout est linéaire
Non ! Mais putain !
Russie mais mec en russie déjà thema la taille du pays il y a tous les paysages
possibles et imaginables en russie allez on y retourne alors.. Oh !
Oh ! sécheresse total ,sécheresse mais ultime tu touches le sol tu te transformes en flaque de poussière c'est beau un
mec c'est trop beau c'est la jungle attend , c'est peut-être un truc genre une île , tu sais une île paradisiaque là ,où les riches y vont en vacances ah
regarder et ça c'est une personne riche
ils ont étendu le linge de cette personne riche sur un fil en or les mecs c'est trop bien je veux aller là-bas
quand je vois ça je pense à des insectes et animaux extrêmement dangereux pour moi c'est l'australie ça s'arrête là putain
je vais l'autre côté c'est peut-être au brésil une nouvelle fois oui c'était au président mec mais le brésil c'est magnifique mec faut qu'on aille
au brésil , venaient on va au brésil demain tous ensemble on fait un petit rebelle billets à 8 millions c'est que tranquille alors là déjà d'après
la balance des blancs de l'image je dirais que c'est une luminosité qui correspond à l'europe , je fais trop le mec , bon en gros c'est juste une
route avec des chanps mort aller , on va mettre au pif.
c'était la france cet endroit nul c'était à bazoche , alors attend une boîte aux lettres américaines on est aux U.S la pipe d'inspecteur Squeezie
c'est le texas ça m'étonnerait pas de voir chuck norris traversé comme ça au fait au feu rouge je pense qu'on est au texas , aller Texas
Oh lala mec ! On est bel et bien au Texas. Ah non pardon... c'était dans le colorado, Texas , Colorado...
qu'est ce que c'est finalement moi ce que j'ai envie de faire c'est les endroits connus les famous place.Ok il y a une grande roue.
Il y a un pont avec de l'eau
il y a des fantômes
Y a Big Ben mais mec c'est Londres c'est le pont il a big ben ne me prenez pas pour un con non plus ça va . POUUUUIYE !!!!
J'était qu'à 1,6 km aller Round suivant. Oh la , il y a un désigual déjà je n'irai pas dans cette ville pour cette raison et un
starbucks on est aux U.S peut-être que j'ai dit une bêtise mais j'ai l'impression que c'est New York.
c'est new york j'ai vu " Thirty Four Streets" c'est new york
ou alors je vous ai menti en réalité j'ai vu que saubusse il est marqué new york city peut-être possible oui
et bim putain mais qu' heureusement
quoi on les bâtards et nous invite dans un
bâtiment attend peut-être par la fenêtre on va voir un drapeau ou un bus avec marc kenis
ça c'est clairement une
statuette d'amik scène je pense qu'on est chez mxm enfin des trucs comme ça pour moi c'est l'italie donc je vais dire italie malheureusement mon
manque de culture fait que je ne serai pas deviner quel bâtiment c memex ac italie c'est obligé on va dire rome
C'est le château de versailles que j'ai visité mangé des petits
Bonsoir je me suis fois et ça arrive alors putain mec sait où ça déjà
samedi un truc voilà la blague que 100% des youtuber peur et jeunes au front en tombant sur paris
merci à tous alors grâce à mes nombreux voyages
je peux vous dire que ça c'est dû courir et que nous sommes en corée etc on est très chanceux parce que sur cette image
on peut apercevoir des triplés et c'est très rare d'en voir n'a en fait j de la mer je pense qu'en chine les mecs totalement
shinji de n'apporter que j'ai dit 100% de la merde les coréens vol me flinguer par contre ou en chine
j'y suis jamais allé comme la chanson de yann tiersen
C'est shanghai bim on n'en parle plus haut à shanghai allez hop c'était pékin bas c'est pareil tu changes tout elle est séparée
14600 poids on est presque pas un culte
Revient c'est quoi ça c'est très probablement chine c'est shanghai faites moi confiance et shanghai et ben c'était
jian guizien je connais même pas cette ville alors que marquez point sur son guide merde on veut pas voir ah
ça c'est du chêne au liban d'asie sein des los
espagne
y a pas vu qu'ils à merde ça c'est bien sûr à madrid c'était au mexique parce que pour moi qu'il ya de l'espagnol en
espagne mais c'est faux à ça je connais ça y'a pas longtemps
gelé a pris dans une vidéo ses axial je vais vous montrer où aller voilà elle n'est pas très connue elle n'en est pas moins
très charmante
voilà vous finirez moins bête alors on est où il ya un trou dans le ciel est ce que veut dire tout ça n'est qu'une
supercherie et qu'on est en fait dans une pièce en réalité augmentée
aux jeunes et adultes je suis désolé je vais dire amérique du nord est ce que j'en sais rien je n'étais pas loin c'était en
dakota du sud
c'est pas dubaï ça avec la tour comme sa pièce
putain heureusement que j'avais regardé en allant au japon les le top des taux les plus hauts du monde à bras ce beau on dirait
disneyland à stanislas et mec sait où mais c'est trop vous avez
petit train touristique de nancy
je pense que c'est un an si je sais pas qui tire cette compagnie de petit tram nancy mais un gros big up a toi
escape à une map juste en france voir si j'arrive à me repérer en france paris c'est parti
est-ce que je connais bien ma propre ville c'est ce qu'on va voir
alors il ya un jean claude biguine ça c'est la l'avenue mozart bien évidemment dans le 16e arrondissement où je suis tombé à
188 matchs tu vas faire ok suivant
bien sûr oui oui je connais bien ce type de briques bien sûr ces débris du 11e s'arrête pas ici ça
Easy money dans le jacuzzi au mini coiffure c'est mon coiffeur je sais parfaitement où c'est mémé coiffure
arrêter avec ces noms de salon c'est à cause de vous je me suis retrouvé à voir cette coupe de cheveux par peur d'aller chez
le coiffeur
17000 point je suis officiellement or ici
Ok on termine par
d'autres endroits très connu dans le monde c'est quoi ce pont c'est pour la vie c'est en france c'est sous le pont d'avignon on y
danse on y danse oui
ça milowe
mai mais qu'à des endroits incroyables sur la planète ça me donne envie de voyager de ouf
men's dastugue l'omc et toilettes des hommes genre tu rentres tu tournes direct bim dans le web
incroyable ces toilettes alors mon avis c'est à las vegas avec les portes bling bling et ou alors peut-être parce que je vis qui a
marqué las vegas sur ce but je sais pas
et voilà un mec un vrai mec ses manières d'après la géographie en s'amusant sans déconner c'est cool et les amis
De stéphane au ciel vous a plu à jouer à ce jeu il est extrêmement cool putain mais trop intéressant de découvrir d'autres paysages
qui sont drastiquement différents j'écaillé drastiquement ça m'a donné envie de voyager mais c'est la rentrée
rip on est tous en pl allez à bientôt